cette école de bus porte le nom d'un
couple d'instituteurs qui a enseigné de
1948 à 1970 mais qui a surtout été
reconnu comme juste pendant la seconde
guerre mondiale ils ont risqué leur vie
pour sauver des juifs
et ce pendant plusieurs mois c'était la
partie vraiment cache en elle même pour
cacher les gens mais il y avait la
partie quotidien c'est à dire de vivre
il fallait qu'ils nourrissent des
personnes supplémentaires pendant la
guerre donc il détourné d'après ce que
l'on sait il détournait des tickets de
rationnement plusieurs fois les bretons
dû déplacer en urgence des enfants pour
éviter des rafles et ont même été menacé
par les nazis un courage sans faille que
tient à rappeler leur beau fils vous
avez des gens qui sont cachés chez vous
que vous ne devriez pas avoir et vous
risquez la mort à cause de ces gens là
et là d'un seul coup vous entendez dans
la rue
des camions des véhicules qui s'arrêtent
des portes qui se ferment qui claquent
des pas dans la rue le cliquetis des
armes
les gens qui viennent frapper à votre
porte et là qu'est ce qui se passe
essayez de vous mettre à leur place la
peur engendrée par ce justement par les
actes qu'ils ont fait c'est l'acte pour
moi le plus fort que l'on puisse faire
sur cette terre
[Musique]
parmi les personnes qui l'ont sauvé
trois membres d'une famille venue
d'ukraine dont anna la petite fille
c'est grâce à cette survivante que les
descendants de thérésia et roger ont pu
retracer toute l'histoire car ceux ci
n'ont jamais voulu mettre en avant ce
moment de leur vie pour eux c'était
quelque chose de normal il n'y avait pas
à dire ce serait faire il leur ferait et
voulait pas du tout un honneur d'être
discret comme ça mais je trouve que
c'est magnifique c'est une belle chose
belle aventure une belle histoire
aujourd'hui décédé et heredia et roger
breton faisait partie d'un réseau de
cette personne qui sauva plusieurs juifs
en eure-et-loir ils sont en tout 28
juste 28 héros à ne pas oublier
[Musique]